[Musik]
andreas hofer tiroler freiheitsheld und
impfgegner
ist er das vorbild für heutige im
verweigerer
fast nirgends lassen sich weniger
menschen impfen als im freiheitlichen
deutschsprachigen alpenraum
gibt es einen zusammenhang mit dem kampf
des andreas hofer
[Musik]
innsbruck hauptstadt des
österreichischen bundeslandes tirol
auf dem bergisel steht das museum tirol
panorama
auf dem wild in die schlacht auf über
1000 quadratmetern stellte der maler
michael senorita darvas 1809 am bergisel
geschah
hier kämpften die tiroler für ihre
freiheit gegen die bayern gegen die
franzosen gegen fremdherrschaft gegen
vorschriften von ganz oben die bayern
wollten die tiroler gegen pocken impfen
ob die nun wollten oder nicht die erste
impfpflicht der geschichte es erinnert
an die gegenwart kleiner anlass große
wirkung
[Musik]
ich glaube gar nicht dass es jetzt bei
dem freiheitskampf tirol gegen die
bayern so sehr ums impfen geht es geht
darum dass ein staat eine maßnahme
einführt und damit sozusagen auch zeigt
werde gut auf hat und das ist das was
mit dem impfen verbunden wird und zwar
auf beiden seiten die bayern die
tatsächlich das als ihre errungenschaft
eben
einbringen durchsetzen wollen um zu
zeigen wer macht hier politik und die
tiroler die sozusagen diesen angriff
abwehren wollen und eben am impfen
sozusagen dieser freiheitskampf
aufbricht ich glaube gar nicht dass es
so sehr ums impfen nur geht sondern vor
allem ganz andere fragen nämlich wer
hier eigentlich jetzt chef im ring ist
sozusagen
moderne gegen tradition
zu zeiten des tiroler freiheitskampfes
hatte man den ersten impfstoff gegen die
pocken gefunden für viele tiroler wie
andreas hofer verstieß sowas aber gegen
gottes gebote ein impfgegner der ersten
stunde nicht in unserem heutigen sinn
ein impfgegner sondern ein bayern-gegner
ein franzosen gegner
der sich gegen diese verordnung gewährt
hat bis heute nimmt man hier
verordnungen nicht gern entgegen
der skiort in tirol es ist der beginn
des zweiten pandemischen winters ob es
wirklich eine ski saison wie früher
geben wird liegt in den händen von ganz
oben
schon 2 andreas wo fast zeiten vor über
200 jahren gab es verschiedene
vorstellungen davon was freiheit ist in
ihr spiel war dies bis zum beginn von
corona der exzess aus bars wie dem kids
loch entsprangen nachweislich die ersten
11.000 infektionen europas
[Musik]
und heute
après ski im wahrsten wortsinne doch der
schoß ist fruchtbar noch aus dem corona
cross
[Musik]
das freiheits konzept von ischgl hieß
ich möchte aber machen was ich will
[Musik]
wie lange geht das noch gut
vor 200 jahren machten die bayern kurzen
prozess mit in verweigern
also bei impfgegnern da holt man zum
teil das ganz große besteck dann raus es
fängt erst mal an mit appellen und
drohung dass man auch jetzt bitte seine
im pflicht nachkommen soll dann gibt es
geldstrafen wenn das immer noch nicht
passiert dann gibt es gefängnisstrafen
und als letzte konsequenz tatsächlich
gibt es dann die zwangsimpfung also die
die impfung unter gewalt heute ist macht
freiwillig doch ab februar soll eine
impfpflicht gelten wenn der staat das
will sind seine staatsbürger dann fremd
beherrscht an der universität innsbruck
schaut man zurück die kirche war für das
impfen viele menschen waren dagegen weil
sie dachten ihnen würde das bayern-team
eingehen eine schwierige sache der
klerus befürwortet die impfung weil der
klerus in dieser zeit teil des staates
geworden ist
vorbehalte finden wir er also in der
bevölkerung wir haben religiöse gründe
um kinder nicht zu impfen und auch ein
soziales motiv
viele kinder sind ein problem für ärmere
familien
das heißt es ist oft ein segen wenn
weniger kinder das erwachsenenalter
erreichen
grausame zeiten
beim tiroler volksaufstand ging es nicht
nur um das im sondern um eine revolte
gegen die moderne und gegen die moderne
medizin
der freiheitskampf ging richtig schief
am ende wurde andreas hofer von den
franzosen geschnappt und hingerichtet
die mein land tirol
lieber sterben als sich impfen zu lassen
das erinnert an die gegenwart